when i started my first business
i didn't know what i was doing i didn't
have mentors i didn't have anybody to
guide me
nobody in my family had been an
entrepreneur before i really had no idea
what i was doing
and as a result i sucked you know i
wasn't getting the sales i wasn't
getting the opportunities i was making
300
a month i was i was frustrated i had a i
had a vision i had a goal you know i
wanted to be a success i was working
hard
i was doing something important you know
i wasn't just trying to rip people off
wasn't just trying to make a lot of
money i
actually believed in what i was doing i
was proud of it but
but i was making all the wrong decisions
and i didn't have the mentors to guide
me
and a man by the name of john became my
first mentor
and he he helped change my life he
helped
transform my business he helped teach me
lessons that
i don't know if i ever would have
learned myself and if i would have it
would have taken me years to do it
and when you can work with somebody
who's accomplished what you want to
accomplish
it just shortcuts your path so quickly
you can learn in
hours what might take you years to
figure out
my passion has always been helping
entrepreneurs and for the past decade
plus it's been
what i breathe what i consume what i'm
all about i love it
to my core i love helping entrepreneurs
and so many people have written in to me
and say evan do you have a
coaching program a mentorship program i
love the videos you know i love the
the newsletters but i i feel like i want
you in my business somehow
and up until now i've typically said no
because it's so time consuming and
because
when i'm involved in something i wanted
to do well
you know i feel like i'm a part of it my
name's not on the on the title but
if my time is being spent on something
i want it to have a major impact right
time is my most valuable commodity i
value how i spend it and
if i'm being involved in something that
has to be doing
something big something that's going to
change the world it has to be that
important
i came back from a trip to asia and i
felt like
i want to do more i want to work with
some entrepreneurs one-on-one to help
them but they have to be at that level
they have to
they have to maybe not be there yet in
terms of achieving your milestones but
you have to want to be there
you have to be willing to to work to get
there you have to be
at the place where you want to make the
world a better place and so i'm
launching
my movement private coaching program
and i'm going to share a little bit
about it in this video
so what you get is a monthly google plus
hangout with me where we're going to
talk about your business
we're going to dissect it we're going to
figure out what's wrong i'm going to be
there to answer your questions
to help you grow to help you get to
where you want to be and and
part of it is building a movement right
so
i want you to have a million views on
your youtube channel to have
hundreds of thousands of people
following you on twitter i i want you to
get to that place where
you're not just building a great
business for yourself but you're an
inspiration
to other people you're a beacon of light
for
for showing people how to become
successful
and build a values-based business to be
able to change the world
and make money in the process i want you
to be a shining example
to help others do the same thing and be
a mentor to them
if only as a public figure instead of
just
working in isolation and building a
business that makes money
and so on our monthly call i helped
guide you through the process and i'm
gonna
i'm gonna push you and i'm gonna
challenge you and i'm gonna make you do
things that
are scary that you've never done before
that
you're hesitant about and you're gonna
give me excuses
and you're going to give me reasons why
you can't do it and really what they all
are are limiting personal beliefs and
i'm going to help you bust through that
and that's honestly the biggest the
biggest
lesson that you can learn is how to bust
through your limiting personal beliefs
because you're operating this bubble we
all are i'm operating my own bubble
and every time you break through
a limiting personal belief you grow
and every major breakthrough that i've
had in my business has come
from busting through a limiting personal
belief and so i'm going to challenge you
to do that
and we're going to break through a lot
of librarian personal beliefs because if
you want to change the world
what you're doing now is not enough it's
not working
right you need to have a bigger impact
you're gonna have to be the best version
of yourself
to get there and it's totally possible
and with my coaching you'll get there
on top of that it's gonna be broadcast
live
to my youtube channel talk about being
put on the spot
this is important because i want people
to follow you
i want people to know who you are i want
you to be a known quantity
to my audience and and eventually to the
world and so
you know companies pay me thousands of
dollars for that kind of exposure
on my channel and that's included for
you guys who are part of the coaching
program
the best part of my day is seeing the
comments that come in on youtube
seeing you guys supporting me and saying
how great something was and how it
impacted their lives
i want that same thing for you because
it's hard
being in business right every day is a
struggle especially in the early days
and you doubt yourself
you're not sure if you're going to make
it and seeing not just my
support and saying hey keep going this
is great you're doing a good job you're
on track
but also people leaving comments and
encouraging you and asking questions
it's fuel it's motivation it gets you
going in the morning and you need that
to be able to succeed okay on top of
that is showing you again
as that expert as a shining light as
somebody to follow and we're going to be
able to track
your journey so every video is live
recorded once a month
on my channel gives you great exposure
trains you to be on camera
and also exposes you to the world of
inspiration that will come from having
great comments and the supportive
community around you
you'll also get ongoing support so in
between our monthly calls you have
access to me by email you want me to
look at a report you're putting out you
want me to look at
some of your campaigns you want some
advice on making your next video
whatever it is you're trying to
hire employees marketing strategy
raising capital
i've gone through that process for
myself and a lot of other businesses you
have access to me
to ask me questions by email throughout
the month because
again when i'm attached to something i
want to be successful
as long as you are part of my program
i want to make sure that everything
you're doing helps you grow
and you're going to be one of the
success stories
you're not just going to get me on email
though you're gonna get priority access
i have two inboxes
okay one of them is for my general
email that comes in i get a lot of email
and sometimes i respond quickly and
sometimes it may take me a week to get
back to somebody
i have a second inbox that's my priority
in box that's where my family is
that's where my big customers are my
corporate clients that's where my key
media contacts are okay you get put in
that box
you get put in the box that my family is
in and i respond to that a lot faster
i check that inbox before i check my
general inbox and i check it at least
once a day and so why do you get
priority access because what you're
doing is important
right because we're trying to change the
world together right so
the questions you have if i can help you
if i can give you
direction to help you do something
that's going to change the world i want
to be a part of that
your work has to be important to justify
the time and so
if you have a question for me i want to
make sure that i can get back to you in
a timely manner
finally get social attention for me okay
i'm going to be following you on twitter
i'm going to be following you on
facebook i'm going to be following you
on youtube i'm going to be
commenting on your stuff i'm going to be
telling you when something
needs to be worked on and improved and
how to do it i'm going to tell you when
you like something
if i love it i'm going to share it with
my audience and give you a lot more
exposure in the process
you're going to get me hounding you
saying hey you know you didn't post
anything
what's going on i spent a lot of time on
social media so you're going to be
hearing a lot from me
and ps you're going to be part of the
family what i want to do really is build
a small network of people who are all
trying to change the world and you can
learn from each other
and support each other and follow each
other and comment on each other's stuff
because
that is there's so much knowledge and
value and motivation and inspiration
that comes from connecting with
like-minded entrepreneurs
the biggest challenge that most people
have is their environment holds you back
right the people you surround yourself
with the media you consume
the environment that you set up wherever
you work it's holding you where you are
it's holding you doing whatever you're
doing right now it's so hard to bust
through
to really break out you have to create
an environment and
people around you who are supportive
who are trying to do something just as
big as you are i want you to join the
family
and have everybody who was part of the
program
as a sounding board as people who are in
your network as people who you can talk
to as people who you can get inspiration
from
because the people who you surround
yourself with will help determine
how far you go on your path to changing
the world
so if that sounds interesting you want
to learn more you can check out
evidence.com
movement you can see more details about
the program you can email me if you're
interested
and i hope to hear from you soon believe